[Musique]
Sylvie vient de viroflet et expose
jusqu'au 27 octobre au conservatoire des
arts de Montini je présente des œuvres
qui ont comme thématique l'élément marin
c'est-à-dire en fait le choc entre la
roche et l'eau si
on regarde et quand dans le mouvement on
y voit effectivement un mouvement d'eau
et un mouvement d'c
on est plus dans l'abstraction dans
l'autre pièce je raconte plus d'histoire
donc ce sont des œuvres qui sont un peu
plus
anciennes qui sont travaillé de façon
plus architecturée je suis plus à la
recherche d'émotions donc je raconte
plus ma vie à travers c'est ce que je
propose au regard et moi ce qui
m'intéresse c'est non pas ce que j'y ai
raconté mais ce que le celui qui passe
va pouvoir y trouver en écho à ce qu'il
est l'œuvre d'art comme miroir du
spectateur une pensée que Sylvie partage
avec un ami de longue date Neville pour
la première fois les deux artistes
expose ensemble Neville présente ses
créations originales des peintures sur
planche de bois ça c'est un désir qui
m'est venu euh au vu de de planches dans
mon atelier de bricolage entre
guillemets au début c'était des des des
bouts de des chutes de bois qui qui
traînaient euh mais maintenant je je
martyrise un peu le bois avant de le
travailler alors- veut dire martyriser
ah carrément à coup de à coup de marteau
ou je casse il faut qu' faut qu' a
cassure une brisure Rabo si circulaire
tous les moyens sont bons pour provoquer
un accident sur le matériau de base
place ensuite à la peinture et à l'ajout
de matières différentes résine polyestè
ardoise ou
vert les peintures posées de Neuville et
les toiles accrochées de Sylvie
communiqu échange coloré dialogue thé
des fils invisibles se sont tissés entre
leurs œuvres cet aspect de planche où il
y a toujours la planche qui apparaît et
un peu de couleur fait référence aussi
au bois qu'on peut trouver en bord de
mer bien que ça soit pas l'histoire de
ces bois à lui moi là j'évoque l'élément
marin
et lui quelque part il y a le le bois
qui peut venir d'un
navire fantôme qui a laissé ses couleurs
sur la plage l'exposition de syv de
eteville est à découvrir au
conservatoire des arts de Montini
jusqu'au samedi 27 octobre